étranger
[Musique]
merci
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
alerte [
Sky rafaeli celegito um elle
l'avait littéralement rencontré sept jours avant que ce
crime ne se produise et il était une grosse
tête de hash donc il y avait un  beaucoup de haschich
et ils étaient défoncés tout le temps
c'est
[Musique] [
Musique]
tapis de bain dans la salle de bain personne n'était
là et elle elle avait pris une douche et
puis elle était retournée voir Raphaël euh
pendant que j'en parlais elle  pensaient que c'était
un peu inhabituel et ils ont essayé d'appeler
Meredith
puis ils ont appelé la police et quand la
police est arrivée et ils ont défoncé la
porte de la chambre de Meredith et c'est à ce moment-là que
le corps a été découvert
Amanda Knox avait euh 20
euh elle venait d'un cassé  à
Seattle et agissant d'une manière qui,
disons, des filles italiennes de cet âge ne connaissez-vous pas les
drogues sexuelles
euh vous savez faire des exercices de yoga au
poste de police après le meurtre de la colocataire,
elle a rapidement attiré l'
attention du procureur la raison
qu'Amanda Knox était dans la peur
était purement sur la base des théories
du procureur local McNamee,
tout le monde était d'abord, puis après cela, il s'agissait
d'eux essayant de trouver un
élément de preuve qui entrerait ensuite
dans ce
qu'il a dit que  le corps le corps de Meredith
euh a été recouvert d'une couette comme il m'a
dit quand je l'ai interviewé c'était
très clair pour lui il a dit que la
femme devait être impliquée car
seule une femme couvrirait le corps d'
une autre femme est
étrangère
[Musique  ]
cas c'est devenu comme un match de football ou
quelque chose comme les trois intérêts nationaux
et c'est devenu sexualisé
que c'est devenu un cirque de spéculation son
surnom était foxy Knox mal c'était
totalement désagréable ça n'avait rien à voir
avec la mort de Meredith Kircher ça
n'avait rien à voir  faire avec la recherche de
la justice Patrick
[Musique]
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
remix
ES
est
[Musique]
c'était un procès de sorcière et le procureur
était un homme très très religieux comme le
religieux hardcore l'attention
s'est immédiatement portée sur cette femme photogénique  et dont la
présence sur la scène du crime a instantanément
provoqué les superstitions traditionnelles de ce procureur,
alors je me suis rendu à Pérouse et je
l'ai interviewé, mais il m'a
immédiatement frappé comme quelqu'un qui n'était pas
intéressé par la raison et la logique et qui
suivait les preuves si j'avais juste le
sentiment de quelqu'un qui  a été détaché
de la réalité, les procureurs ont déclaré que l'ADN de Knox
avait été trouvé sur le manche du couteau tandis que l'
ADN de la victime avait été trouvé sur la lame.
trouvé sur la
lame était si rare et peu fiable qu'il n'y
a aucune preuve pour dire que c'était l'
ADN de Meredith, mais surtout,
le couteau était trop gros, il ne correspondait pas
aux blessures qu'elle avait sur la
cellule sur le corps
mais vous pouvez  voir des images des images vidéo de
diverses personnes de différents éléments
des autorités italiennes entrant
sur la scène du crime il y a une
séquence vidéo d'eux et il s'agit simplement de briser
la vitre de la porte et de lui donner des coups de pied
pour essayer d'entrer
d'accord
ce n'est pas  professionnalisme léger
que vous imaginez voir dans d'autres
endroits, il était assez clair que
tout était contaminé, donc tout
ce qu'ils ont collecté sur cette
scène de crime était très peu utile à part
une empreinte sanglante qui
correspondait entièrement à la taille et aux chaussures qui étaient
porté par de très bons
mois avant les meurtriers l'été
avant les meurtres, il faisait en fait des
cambriolages à domicile en cambriolant
euh vider ce qu'il pensait être des
bureaux et des maisons vides lors de sa première
conversation qu'ils ont enregistrée Rudy bonne
journée dit qu'Amanda n'avait rien à voir avec
ça
dès qu'il est revenu à Paris, il a
commencé à la mettre en ouais
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir un
diplôme en droit pour comprendre ce qui se passait là-
bas
quand ils ont compris qu'il était
impliqué, ils n'ont pas fait demi-tour
ils ont juste continué et ils l'
ont fait parce qu'il y avait 20 camions de télévision sur
la Piazza et ils ne pouvaient pas se lever
devant eux et dire que nous avons fait une énorme
erreur ici
[Musique]
original [
Musique]
J'aime la stéréo au tribunal en
couleur  manifestation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je pense que si vous retourniez en Italie en ce
moment, vous pourriez demander à n'importe qui Je dirai oui,
c'est une tueuse, ils l'ont fait sortir, nous
demandons maintenant respectueusement à
Amanda et au reste de notre famille notre
vie privée dont nous avons besoin  remettre de
cette horrible épreuve merci nous avons
été presque oubliés dans tous les
médias les photos ne sont pas vraiment d'elle
euh il n'y a pas grand chose sur ce qui
s'est réellement passé au début
euh donc c'est très difficile de
garder sa mémoire vivante
[Musique  ]
définitivement
étranger
euh
sporka est putana
appelé contrario
PDG de la Republica le consommateur
[Musique]